Speaker 1: We must follow up. I am driven.
I am determined to follow up about a story
that is increasingly smelling like Watergate.
Yesterday, I told you about these roughly seven
hours of missing call logs that the Trump White
House has turned over to the January 6th Committee
investigating the Trump riots. So to reset the
entire thing and get everybody on the same page
for a period of time now. The January 6th
Committee has been wanting the logs of who did
Donald Trump speak to on January 6th. And it turns
out that what was provided to the investigative
committee is missing seven hours. And as I told
you yesterday, this was during some very key hours
between 11:17 a.m. and 6:54 p.m. This is the most
important time of the riots. It's from just before
they started heading towards the Capitol through
the period of time during which we now know Trump
was being urged even by people in his family, like
Ivanka to call in the National Guard, tell people
to go home to the point at which Donald Trump
gave that very mealy mouthed and soft and squishy
appeal to his followers to go home, even though
they were completely right to be there. Because
the election, after all, was stolen. As Trump said
through to when people actually started leaving
the Capitol. This is the key time we're going to
follow up in a moment on Donald Trump's claim that
he doesn't know what a burner phone is because one
of the aspects of this is not only our seven hours
missing. Even if Trump didn't make any phone
calls on White House phones during that time,
he clearly was talking to people and he may have
been using burner phones. We're going to follow up
about that in the next segment, but the first
part of this is that Talking Points memo has
done something fascinating, which is they have
assembled media reports where others acknowledge
speaking to Trump during that time, and they are
now able to say with a high degree of certainty,
here are at least some of the calls missing from
the call logs now, whether they're missing because
they're just missing and haven't been turned over,
or whether they're missing because burner phones
or other people's phones were used, we don't
yet know, but this is very, very interesting.
Talking Points Memo Trump was one hundred percent
making phone calls during the January 6th attack.
Here's the list and what they've done is they've
assembled media reports and they've said here,
here are calls that have been acknowledged
which aren't recorded anywhere. So, for example,
Mike Pence, the official records turned over to
the committee, don't include Trump's final call
with Mike Pence on January 6th, during which the
president made a last attempt to pressure Pence
to illegally hijack the election certification
process. Then Pence adviser, general Keith
Kellogg, testified under oath about the
conversation. The Washington Post reported on the
call Bob Woodward and Robert Costa surface to call
in their book peril. So that is a specific call
with three sources that is not on the logs.
So that's that's a call. There's no record
of it and what the Trump administration has
turned over to investigators. OK, next call.
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy. We
know about this call. Trump had an explosive
call with the House Minority Leader Kevin
McCarthy, right in the middle of the attack.
Representative Jaime Herrera, Butler confirmed
the call, said McCarthy briefed her on the call.
That's the conversation where Trump, responding
to the GOP leader sounding the alarm of violence,
remarked, Well, Kevin, I guess the people are
more upset about the election than you are,
according to Butler. That's a specific call
that we have independently sourced. It's not
on the records turned over by Trump, so that's
another call that took place during those seven
hours. Senators Mike Lee and Tommy Tuberville,
Senator Mike Lee told the Salt Lake Tribune he
got a call from Trump moments after the Capitol
Police stopped the Senate proceedings. I believe
that was around 1:30 p.m. Eastern. I'm going. It
was a crazy day. I'm going from memory, but it's
certainly within that seven hour window of missing
calls. The caller ID indicated the call was coming
from the White House, according to Lee, but he
didn't know it was Trump until he picked up.
According to Lee, Trump mis dialed and was trying
to call Senator Tommy Tuberville. So hand that his
phone to the Alabama senator in the wake of the
attack, Tuberville revealed he told Trump in the
call that Pence was being evacuated. Third call
missing from the logs. Trump was on the phone this
call from the White House, so this was not with a
burner phone. The caller ID was the White House.
Jim Jordan, now this one we've spoken about so
many times and Jim Jordan has been extremely
dishonest and deceptive about how many times did
you speak to Trump on that day? The official call
logs include one call between Trump and
Jordan at 9:24 a.m. We now know with the
benefit of hindsight. Jordan has admitted to
more than one call that day, and at least one
was during the attack. So at minimum, we know
that there is one acknowledged Jim Jordan call
not reflected in the records turned over by
Trump. And then lastly, Congressman Matt Gaetz,
Politico, reported that Gates was
on one of Jordan's calls to Trump,
during which they urged Trump to call off the
supporters storming the building. So that is.
Gates himself has refused to say if he was part
of the call. But Politico? He hasn't denied it,
and Politico has reported it. So again, that if
that's with Jim Jordan and during the attacks,
it's during that seven hour window. These are
all easily verified by public statements. And
of course, I don't know if and how Republicans
will even try to spin this. They will probably say
it's a fishing expedition. This is a bad faith
committee. It's a committee that needs to be
ended its politically oriented because they
don't have any Republicans other than two
anti-Trump Republicans. That's because they refuse
to be on it. Everybody else refused to be on it.
So we do have the ability to figure out at least
some of these calls. Records can be cross-checked
and then from the standpoint of the investigative
committee, if they successfully subpoena the phone
records of the people on the other ends of these
phone calls, then they would be able to say, Well,
here's a call in Jim Jordan's phone log. And it's
not reflected in what the White House gave us.
That's a call that they have hidden from us.
So clearly, that's something that they can do,
and this is thinking more and more like
like Watergate, and we're going to talk
about that a little later. Let's now dig in
a little bit to the whole burner phone thing